في اسبوعها ثالث الاشتباكات بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع مستمره رغم
الهدنه
[موسيقى]
الجيش السوداني ينفل العربيه تقارير
الاعلاميه عن نقله للحرب الى دارفور
تعد هذه الرحله وهذه السفينه هي الاكبر
منذ بدء عمليات الاجلاء كعددا وحجما حتى
هذه السفينه السعوديه امانه تنفذ اكبر
عمليه اجلاء من السودان نحو الفي شخصا من
جنسيات مختلفه
استطلاع راي حديث يكشف عن ثقه اكثر من 80%
من الروس بالرئيس فلاديمير بوتين
احييكم مشاهدينا ما زالت العربيه في هذه
التغطيه المستمره لتطورات في السودان
وطبعا لابرز الاخبار الدوليه فيما يتعلق
بالتطورات المتعلقه بالسودان تتواصلوا
الاشتباكات بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريه
في عده نقاط خاصه العاصمه الخرطومه رغم
موافقه الطرفين على هدنه خامسه لوقف اطلاق
النار كما تشهد سماء الخرطوم تحليقا كثيفا
لطائرات حربيه وفي وقت تسمع اصوات ويل
مدفعيه ومضادات الطائرات اما في مدينه ام
درمان ادى سقوط قذيفه على احد المنازل الى
مقتل شخص
[تصفيق]
اه طبعا مشاهدينا هذه الصوره مباشره على
شاشه قناه العربيه الان للخرطوم حيث ان
نتابع هذه هذه هذا الدخان المتصاعد في
الخرطوم طبعا هذه المنطقه بذات يعني منذ
الامس وكنا نتابع سحب الدخان تطالها يبدو
بانه الاشتباكات او القصف يتمركز حاليا في
هذه النقطه من الخرطوم على الرغم من
الهدنه المعلنه بين طرفي النزاع
قال الجيش السوداني في بيان رسمي انما حصل
كان محاوله فاشله للاستيلاء على الحكم
بقوه المتمردين واكد بان محاولات
المتمردين واعوانهم من عملاء داخل والخارج
في التسويق لمشروعهم القائم على تزييف
الحقائق قد فشلت واشار البيان الى ان
المعركه وحدت الشعب وقوته المسلحه وزادت
من حرص ابناء الوطن على اهميه بقاء قوته
المسلحه كما اكد البيان على العمل على
تهيئه الظروف المناسبه لكل اجهزه الدوله
لاستئناف عملها وعوده الحياه لطبيعتها
باسرع وقت ممكن
بدورها اتهمت قوات الدعم السريع الجيش
السوداني بخرق الهدنه الانسانيه المتفق
عليها عبر مهاجمه مراكزها وعدد من الاحياء
السكنيه في الخرطوم بواسطه الطيران
والمدفعيه هذا وجددت قوات الدعم السريع في
بيان لها التزامها الكامل بالهدنه
الانسانيه المعلنه لفتح ممرات امنه
للمواطنين لقضاء احتياجاتهم ولتسهيل
عمليات الاجلاء
من ام درمان ينضم الينا الصحفي عمار ابو
شيبه عمار اهلا بك معنا منذ لحظات كنا
نتابع صوره على شاشه العربيه حيث الدخان
يتصاعد في احدى المناطق والمدن والاحياء
في الخرطوم هل يمكن ان تعطينا صوره ماذا
يجري ومن اين ياتي هذا الدخان ما هي هذه
المنطقه اين تقع
منذ الصباح البكر وذكرت هنالك عدد من
الاشتراكات في وسط العاصمه الخرطوم هذا
المكان يشير الى وسط العاصمه الخرطوم كانت
هناك اشتباكات في هذه المنطقه والتي ربما
يعني خفضت فيها حده الاشتباكات لعكس
الايام الاولى التي كانت فيها الاشتباكات
عنيفه وكبيره جدا من مضطر الطرفين
باستخدام المدفعيات الثقيله
والتحرك الكبير في هذه المنطقه
مدينه
صباح شهاده الاشتباكات
المتقاعده ربما كانت هذه الاشتباكات ما
بين المضادات الارضيه
وترد على طائرات
القوات المسلحه التي سنتغرب جويه هذه
الارضيه يعني اصبحت
نسمعها او نسمعها بكثافه كبيره
واصواتها يعني منذ الصباح الباكر ولكنها
لم تستطيع
اسقاط الطائرات او اصابه هذه الطائرات على
مستوى مدينه بحري ما زال الوضع كما هو
عليه اشتباكات متقطعك في المناطق الشرقيه
الشرقيه
للمدينه خاصه منطقه كافوري ومناطق شرق
النيل كانت هناك معلومات وردت الينا من
وسط عاصي والخرطوم عن ان هنالك ربما
تحركات على الاعدام هناك حديث
تتحرك داخل هذه المناطق والتي من خلالها
نشاهدها من خلال الصوره هذا ما يعني ان
هنالك التكتيك العسكريه الجديده بدا في
الميدان وهذا يتزال من ايضا مع
تصريحات بالنسبه للحركه هل عادت الحركه
الى طبيعتها في بعض الاماكن وخاصه في ام
درمان هل فتحت المحاله التجاريه الصيدليات
هل تصل المواد الغذائيه اذا هذه المحاله
التجاريه من قبل التجار
نعم ربما هو استفاده من
الحوامش الخاصه والمتعلقه بالهدنه نعم هنا
تنضرب هنا عاده الحياه بنسبه كبيره الى
طبيعتها المحاله التجاريه تعمل بشكل جزئي
ولكنه فعال
عده الى المدينه والكبيره بدات تعود اليها
نوعا من الحياه التجاريه بدات تعمل بدء
المواطنون يذهبون للتبضع فيها شيئا ما
ولكن بحذر وهذا بارتباط الوضع الامن العام
في البلاد
الصيدليات تعمل وهنالك نقص نعم في عدد من
الادويه وعدد من الاحتياجات الطبيه
المستشفيات ايضا كذلك بدات تستقبل عدد
من الوسط في منطقه
وما فيها من كثافه سكانيه عاليه نعم هنالك
كانت اصابات الصباح في منطقه حامل لعدت
الى وفاه احد الضحايا في تلك المنطقه باحد
القبائل الطائشه التي سقطت على المنازل
والاقتراب هذه المنطقه ايضا كذلك من مناطق
اشتباك وصراع خطوط الاتصال خطوط الكهرباء
الخدمات العامه نوعا ما هي جيده وتعمل
فعاليه ما جعله هنالك استقرارا نسبيا في
هذه المنطقه طبعا ما كان هناك بعض الانباء
تتحدث عن
احد الاطراف او بعض القوات العسكريه من
الطرفين يسيطرون على بعض المستشفيات
دقه هذه المعلومات
هنا الحديث ربما بشكل كبير عن
القلب العاصمه الخرطوم وهذه المناطق
اشتباك وصراعه كبيره منذ اللحظه الاولى
وشاهدنا كثير جدا من الفيديوهات
والمناشدات باخراج المرضى والجرحى اثناء
وبعد وقبل هذه المعارك يعني بشكل كبير او
بعد المعارك يعني هذه المستشفيات يعني كل
طرف يعني لا يتحدث لانه يسيطر عليها او لا
ولكن الجيش في بيان اكد من خلاله ان مفروض
الدعم السريع حولت هذه المستشفيات الى
سكنات او سكنات عسكريه
تقول بانها لا تتواجد داخل هذه المناطق
هناك معلومه اخرى من الامم المتحده كانت
قد اشارت اليها قبل قبل ايام
بانها تتخوف من خطر بيولوجي فيما يخص
المعمل المعمل القومي معمل الاشتراك في
وسط العطف الخرطوم لان القوات السريه
سيطرت عليه وهنا الاشاره لان الدخول الى
الاسلام يعني معامل او مستشفيات ليس هو من
اختصاصات او من مهام قوات الدعم السريعه
هذه المعامل او المستشفيات تؤمن بواسطه
وبالتنسيق مع وزاره الصحه الان وضعت الصحي
داخل هذه المستشفىات شبه معدوم لانه يقع
في منطقه اشتباك كبيره ما بين القوات على
ارض الميدان ويصعب حتى الوصول لتلك
المنطقه لان الجسور التي تربط المدن
العاصمه الثلاث مع هذه المنطقه هي معطوبه
ويصعب فيها الحركه بشكل واضح وكبير شكرا
لك عمار ابو شيبه الصحفي كنت معي من ام
درمان
قال مسؤول في الجيش السوداني في تصريحات
للعربيه ان التقارير التي تتحدث عن نقل
الجيش المعركه لدارفور هي مضلله واتهم
المسؤول لقوات الدعم السريع في دار فورد
بمهاجمه قوات الجيش واثاره الفتنه بين
القبائل من جهته قال رئيس مجلس السياده
السودانيه عبد الفتاح البرهان انه لن يكون
هناك رافعه لاي كيان او حزبا او جماعه
للانقضاض على السلطه واكد البرهان ان
الجيش السوداني ملتزم بالعمليات السياسيه
التي تقود لقيام سلطه مدنيه على حد وصفه
اما نقابه اطباء السودان فافادت بارتفاع
ضحايا الاشتباكات في البلاد الى 411 قتيلا
من المدنيين واصابه
2023 اخرين واوضحت النقابه في بيان ان
الاقتتال الاخير في مدينه الجنينه او قاعه
89 قتيلا مشيره الى انه لا يوجد حصر دقيق
لعدد الاصابات واضافت النقابه ان جميع
المستشفيات في المدينه
خارج الخدمه
من الخرطوم ينضم الى دكتور عطيه عبد الله
عطيه سكرتير نقابه اطباء السودان دكتور
عطيه اهلا بكم معنا كيف يمكن ان تصف لنا
وضع المستشفيات اليوم خاصه بانه يبدو بهذه
الهدنه هناك بعض الممرات الامنه والناس
يعني تستطيع الى حد ما ان تتحرك
في البلده السلام عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى
وبركاته
جماهير الشعب السوداني الصحه والعافيه لكل
الجرحى والمرضى وعوده حميدا لكل المفقودين
نعم كما ذكر ذكرتي في في استعراض
لمجريات الاحداث حتى
صبيحه اليوم
في شهداء وايضا
الجرحى والمصابين وايضا
عدم القدره على الوصول الى المستشفيات هذه
الفودن انما هي تصدر كثيرا بهذه الخدمه
الخامسه على وجه الدقه ولكن هي ايضا بدون
اي ضمانات كل الذي يحدث انما هي محاولات
فرديه من عدد من الكرادر الطبيه للوصول
الى المستشفيات ومحاوله ادا واجبهم المهني
والاخلاقي طيب بالنسبه للمستلزمات الطبيه
والادويه هل تتمكنون من الحصول عليها
نتحصل عليها من الشركاء والمنظمات القريبه
التي استطاعت الوصول الى مخازنها وايضا
المخازن القريبه جدا هنالك ايضا يعني تم
شراء وتوفير عدد من المستخدمات من الاماكن
القريبه لكن الذي اريد ان اؤكده ان هنالك
ليس هنالك ضمانات للممرات الامنه فهنالك
ما يحدث في الجنين انما هي مدى انسانيه
مجزره بشريه مخالف لكل
القوانين الدوليه الذي يحدث ان هنالك حرب
مستعره جدا والان نحن حتى الان
لا نحصي عدد الجرحى وايضا الشهداء لصعوبه
الوصول اليهم كل المستشفيات العامه
والخاصه في تلك المدينه انما هي متوقفه
تماما
الدوليه دكتور عطيه متواجده هناك للمساعده
اقله
نعم هنالك منظمات على ارض الواقع
ولكن هذه المنظمات
لا تستطيعين اي عون بعد الحوادث النهب
والسرقه والقتل حتى الان استش اكثر من 13
شهيد من الكوادر الطبيه انما هو مؤشر خطير
حتى ارتفع عدد المستشفيات التي تم
استهدافها الى 15 فقط في الجنينه ام في
عموم السودان
ومنذ بدايه الحرب في في مدينه الجنينه حتى
الان نشتري شراء طبيب واحد له الرحمه
والمغفره لاسرته التعازي ولكن اذا استمر
هذا الحال ونحن الان يعني نتحدث عن 13 او
14 شهيد منذ بدايه الحرب انما يعني بمعدل
شهيد يوميا الامر خطير جدا عدد الشهداء
ايضا
وسط المدنيين يزداد يوما بعد يوم
عطيه وضع المستشفيات وخاصه مثلا في
الخرطومه هل يعني هل لديكم احصائيه كم
مستشفى هي خارج الخدمه كمستشفى هي تعمل
موضوع تمركز بعض الاطراف المتصارعه في
المستشفيات هل يمكن ان تعطينا معلومات
دقيقه حول ذلك والصوره واضحه عن وضع
المستشفيات
اي نعم المستشفيات عدد قليل يعمل حتى الان
نحن نتحدث حوالي الى حوالي 25 مستشفى يعمل
الان يعمل بطاقه اقل بكثير من المتوقع
معمل استحق القومي في في قلب الخرطوم
واحتل من القوات الدعم السريع
وايضا حتى بقيه هذه المستشفيات يعني نحاول
مجتهدين جدا لتشغيل المستشار طرفيه لانه
يعني هي اصبحت الامن للمرضى للوصول اليها
ولكن نصطدم بعقابات لوجستيه كبيره جدا في
تشغيل هذه المستشفيات ما لم تتوقف هذه
الحرب العباسيه فورا يمكن لا يمكن الحديث
اصلا عن تشغيل كل المستشفيات بطاقه
استيعابيه كبيره نحب نعرف اكثر عن هذا
المصنع لانه حتى
الامم المتحده ايضا حذرت من من موضوع هذا
المصنع تقول بانه الدعم السريع يسيطر عليك
ولكن المسؤولين
المسؤولين عن هذا المصنع من الاطباء
المختصين هل متواجدين في هذا المصنع ام لا
فقط العسكر
المصنع والمعمل
المعمل
المعمل اشترك هو معمل كبير جدا معمل
النظام الى الطرفين
بهولوجيه كبيره جدا من المثاليه والحصبه
وايضا
عدد من من العينات التي يمكن في حال
انتشار ان تسبب او
يعني لذلك نسال دكتور عطيه هل هل متواجد
اناس مختصون هناك للحقول دون ذلك
بالتاكيد لا بالتاكيد لانه هنالك يعني
اصدقائي الاخرى ثم طرد كل الكوادر الطبيه
وفي نفس المبنى يقع بنك الدم المركزي الذي
منذ اليوم الاول تم يعني حتى توزيع مخزون
الدم فيه لعدم امكانيه الوصول اليه هذا
الموقع يعني يقع على بعد امتار من القياده
قياده القوات المسلحه
يعني في مرمى النيران من الطرفين منذ
اليوم الاول شكرا لك
نقابه اطباء السودان على المشاركه معنا
الجيش السوداني اتهم قوات الدعم السريع
بادخال اسلحه وجنودنا لمستشفى الخرطوم
وبتحويل المستشفى وبعض المدارس لتقنيه
وجاء في البيان ان المتمردين مستمرون بقصف
الخرطوم وام درمان لاجبار السكان على
الاخلاء لافتا الى ان القصف العشوائي
مستمر بمحيطي قياده بحري والقياده العامه
والدفاع الجوي واضاف الجيش انه نفذ عمليات
اجلاء عبر مطاري وادي سيدنا وبورتسودان
لرعايه بعض الدول
ابدا قوات بل قائد قوات الدعم السريع في
مقابله مع قناه بي بي سي استعداده لاجراء
مفاوضات مع قائد الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان
بشرط وقف اطلاق النار وقال حميتي لهيئه
الاذاعه البريطانيه انه طالب بالهدنه منذ
اليوم الاول للحرب وان قوته بدات بفتح
ممرات انسانيه داخل مناطق سيطرتها
وفي تصريح ان العربيه قال يوسف عزت
المستشار السياسي لقائد قوات الدعم السريع
محمد حمدان دقلو ان قوته سيطرت على 90% من
ولايه الخرطوم وانها تستطيع الصمود في
المعارك لسنوات يوسف عزت لفتا الى ان
المعركه فرضت على الدعم السريع وان وقف
اطلاق النار مرتبط بتنفيذ الجيش لذلك كما
اكد عزت في لقائه مع العربيه ان البرهان
لا يدير المعركه ولا يستطيع وقفا النار
دعت المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا
في تصريحات لصحيفه عربي نيوز دعت طرف
السودان الى الاتفاق على وقف دائم لاطلاق
النار وحل الخلافات من خلال المفاوضات
زخرفه اضافت ايضا ان روسيا تبذل كل الجهود
اللازمه لضمان سلامه المواطنين الروسي
الموجودين حاليا في السودان مشيره الى ان
بلادها على اتصال دائم مع جميع الدول ذات
الصله بما في ذلك السعوديه
مع دخول المواجهات يومها الخامس عشر تواصل
عواصم الدول الاجلاء رعاياها والهاربين من
القتال الدائر في السودان منذ اسبوعين
السعوديات تمثل نقطه عبور رئيسيه لعدد من
هذه الدول عبر ميناء جده الاسلامي وقاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه وقاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه
[موسيقى]
في هذا السياق قالت الخارجيه السعوديه
انها اجلت
4,738 شخصا من السودان من رعايه 96 دوله
وذلك منذ بدء الاشتباكات في السودان كما
اشارت الخارجيه السعوديه الى انه تم اجلاء
139 مواطنا سعوديا من السودان حيث يتم
توفير الاحتياجات الاساسيه للرعايه تمهيدا
لتسهيل مغادرتهم الى بلدانهم
قبل ذلك قال العقيده مسفر الجريني المتحدث
الرسمي لحرس الحدود السعودي في تصريحاتنا
العربيه ان حرس الحدود في ميناء جده سخر
جميع الامكانيات البشريه والماديه
والتقنيه لاستقبال ضيوف عمليات الاجلاء من
السودان حيث وصلت سفينتان صينيتان تحملان
رعايه من الصين وباكستان باشر حرس الحدود
مهام من ضمن الاعمال والمهام المنوطه
بوزاره الداخليه والقطاعاتها
المشاركه في تقديم المساعده في عمليات
الاجلاء
المواطنين او الرعايه الدول الصديقه
والشقيقه من السودان الى ميناء جده
الاسلامي والتي سنحت لهم حكومه المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
عمليه الاجلاء الى حتى وصولهم الى جده ومن
ثم المغادره الى بلادهم بكل امن وسلامه
يقوم حرص حدود بالعديد من المهام من ضمنها
حفظ الامن والسلامه داخل الميناء وكذلك
المنطقه المحيطه به كما يقوم حرس حدود
بتنظيم الحافلات والمركبات داخل الميناء
لتحقيق الامن والسلامه للجميع طبعا سخر
حرس حدود جميع الامكانيات الماديه
والبشريه والتقنيه لخدمه هؤلاء القادمين
الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه
[موسيقى]
قال المستشار في منظمه الامم المتحده
بمنطقه الشرق الاوسط تامر حموده في مقابله
خاصه مع العربيه قال ان الحكومه السعوديه
قدمت كل الدعم اللازم لعمليه اخلاء
الموظفين من ميناء بورتسودان الى ميناء
جده مشيدا بجهود السلطات السعوديه
قدمت كل الدعم اللازم لاخلاء عمليه اخلاء
الموظفين من اول ميناء بورسودان لغايه ما
وصلوا بناء جده ومن ميناء جده استقبلته من
الحكومه السعوديه مع
المتحده الموجوده في المملكه وتم
استضافتهم وتم تسهيل عمليه خروجهم من
ميناء جده الى مطار جده وتم نقلهم الى
مكان اخر احنا من ناحيه الامم المتحده
احنا شايفين مجهود جبار من الحكومه
السعوديه لمساعده كل اللاجئين
المحتاجين الاخلاء من من السودان
عبر رئيس الوفد الايراني في الرياض
للعربيه على امتنانه للتسهيلات التي
قدمتها السعوديه لاجلاء الرعايه الاجانب
من السودان مشددا على اهميه التعاون بين
البلدين
نحن شاكرون للسعوديه ولوزاره الخارجيه
ومكتبها في جده هذا تعاون جيد بين البلدين
ولدين نيه للتعاون بشكل اكبر
من جهته قال القنصل اليمني في السعوديه
على وبثقيها في حديثنا العربيه انه تم
اجلاء مائه وتسعه وثلاثين مواطنا يمنيا من
السودان اليوم مع منحهم تاشيره حكوميه
لمده شهر مضيفا في الوقت ذاته انه تمت
مغادره 60 مواطنا يمنيا الى اليمن طبعا
اليوم هي ثاني الرحله في اطار عدد من
الرحلات الرحله الاولى كانت من يومين وتم
وصول في حدود مياه تقريبا 100 139
مواطن يمني ما بين افراد واسر وتم طبعا
استقبالهم هنا وانهاء جميع اجراءاتهم في
قسم الجوازات بشكل سلس وبشكل مريح جدا ومن
ثم تفويجهم الى الفنادق من خلال موجودين
هناك
مع منحهم
تاشيره حكوميه لمده شهر كثير من اليمنيين
استغلوها لاداء عمره موجودين في الاماكن
المقد هنا وجزء منهم بعد ما نهوها تقريبا
امس قمنا باعاده تفويج ما يقارب 60 مواطن
يمني ومعظم من الاسر الى المناطق اليمنيه
ما بين رحلتين الى مارب والى
عدن بدعم من وزاره الخارجيه ومجلس الوزراء
من قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه في جده ينضم
الينا مراسل العربيه سلطان السلمي سلطان
اهلا بك معنا الاجواء لديك هذه تعد اكبر
عمليه اجلاء اليوم
بالفعل اليوم تعد سفينه امانه السفير
المدنيه التجاريه التابعه للحكومه
السعوديه كان على متنها 20 مواطن السعودي
و186 مواطن اجنبي باختلاف جنسيات وكان على
متن هذه السفينه كذلك
155 شخص من موظفي من منظمه الامم المتحده
وكذلك 65 مواطن ايراني دقائق محدوده
وقد تتم الانتهاء من عمليات الانزال بشكل
كبير سوف تنقلهم هذه الحافلات وهي عددها
47 حافله تم تخصيصها من قبل السلطات
السعوديه لنقل كافه الرعايه من الذين تم
انزالهم من سفينه امانه الى مساكنهم هنا
بجده قبل الخوف في تفاصيل اخرى لنضم معي
الان الاستاذ الدكتوره نتعرف عليك اولا
دكتوره غاده مطر ناشطه بحقوق الانسان
والمراه سودانيه وافتخر
الاشتباكات المسلحه هناك بما انك انت وصلت
الان من السودان طبعا
كالعاده في كل الحروب والاشتباكات
والقضايا تكون دائما المراه هي المظلومه
الاكبر لانها هي تكون همها الاكبر اسرتها
واطفالها وهي بتحمل هم المعيشه وهم
الاستمرار في الحياه هي المحرك والدينامو
الاول للاسره في كل المجتمعات العربيه
وغيرها
الحال في السودان من ثوره ديسمبر كان حال
جميل وكاله المراه مع مع الرجل في خطوه
واحده في سبيل تطور وتنميه وطن السودان
لكن نسبه للاطماع العساكر والمليشيات من
الدعم السريع والحركات المسلحه للاسف
انهارت كل الاحلام والامنيات التي كنا
نتوقعها في ظل سودان جميل ومن هنا نحن
بنقول انه نحن سوف نعود وحتم النعود للكوخ
الموشح بال سنعود يا سوداننا وسنعود اجمل
وشكر هنا للمملكه العربيه السعوديه وخادم
الحرمين الشريفين يعني استضافته لينا
وارسال الباخره وجينا من بورسودان وقبلها
من مدني ومن الخرطوم من ديارنا والذين
اخرجوا من ديارهم بغير حقه الا ان يقولوا
ربنا الله سنتمنى العوده القريبه باذن
الله وشكرا لكم شكرا الان سوف ننتقل
للاحدى او سوف نصعد الى احدى الحافلات
التي تم تخصيصها من قبل سلطه السعوديه
لنقل كافه الرعايه من هنا من قاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه بجده الى المساكن المخصصه
لهم هذه الحافلات على متن كل حافله خمسه
واربعين شخص يتحدث عن 47 حافله تم تخصيصها
لهؤلاء الرعايه لنقل من مساكنهم بعد ان تم
انهاء كافه اجراءات السفر الخاصه بهؤلاء
الرعايه نشاهد لنا هذه الحافلات المكيفه
سوف يرافقه بعدد من الموظفين السعوديين في
عدم القطاعات الحكوميه للتاكد من وصولهم
سكني وانهاء اجراءات عمليه التسكين وكذلك
وجودهم داخل هذه الفنادق حتى يتم تلبيه
كافه الاحتياجات الخاصه بهؤلاء الرعايه
اثناء مده اقامتهم هناك في المساكن
المتوقع في ظرف 48 ساعه سوف يتم انها كافه
الاجراءات الخاصه بالمواطنين الاجانب حتى
يستعدون للسفر الى بلدانهم بعد تلبيه
وتسهيل كافه احتياجاتهم اقامه مدير العامه
للجوازات بمنحه التاشيره استثنائيه لمده
شهر لهؤلاء الرعايه حتى يخوضون قسطا من
الراحه ومن ثم بعد ذلك يتم البث في
اجراءاتهم بشكل مباشر
وسريع ايضا في المنطقه المجاهد المقابله
تبقت على متن السفينه تبقت اعداد محدوده
جدا وقد لا تتجاوز المئه وخمسين شخص بعد
دمه بعد ان تم نقل اعداد كبيره من هؤلاء
الرعايه لمقرات السكن وانهاء اجراب
اجراتهم في ظرف الساعه واحده اخذت عمليه
الزلزال من هذه السفينه لعشرين مواطن
سعودي و1,86 مواطن اجنبي ثلاث ساعات فقط
وسط ممرا شرفي وسط استقبال من قبل السفراء
الاجانب
والقناصل هنا بالسفارات بالاجنبيه بجده
لاستكمال الاوراق الثبوتيه لهؤلاء الرعايه
وانهاء كافه اجراءاتهم وبعد كذلك ان تم
التاكد من سلامتهم واصحه اتمنى نشاهد هذا
الحافله الان بدات بعد ان يتم امتلاع
الحافله تنتقل فورا الى مقر السكن في عبر
طرق تنظيميه دقيقه جدا وبعداد محدده لكل
حافله ومرافقين سعوديين لهذه الحافلات حتى
الوصول الى مقرات سكر النار شكرا لك من
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه في جده مراسل
العربيه سلطان السلمي دائما سنكون معك مع
باقي الزملاء لدى وصول اي طائره او اي
سفينه تحمل الرعايه من السودان
ونتابع معكم الان مشاهدينا هذه الصور
لانتشار قوات الشرطه في جميع ولايات
الخرطومات اذا هذه الصور هي
الشرطه تنتشر في جميع ولايات الخرطوم هذا
ما حصلنا عليه في هذه الصور بانه قوات
الشرطه
تقوم بالانتشار او تنتشر في جميع ولايات
الخرطوم
وصلت طائره تقل اكثر من 340 مواطنا صينيا
تم اجلائه من السودان عبر السعوديه الى
الصين حيث كان من بين المواطنين الصينيين
الموجودين على متن الطائره مدرسون في معهد
كونفوشيوس وموظفون في شركات مملوكه للدوله
بحسب وسائل الاعلام صينيه
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الاوكرانيه 87 من
مواطنيها معظمهم من الطيارين وفني
الطائرات وعائلاتهم وذلك ضمن 138 مدنيا في
المجمل من بينهم مواطنون من جورجيا من جهه
اخرى لم تعلن روسيا بعد عن اي اجلاء
لاعضاء سفارتها او رعاياها من الخرطوم
وقال المتحدث باسم الكريم
على اتصالا وثيق بموسكو مؤكدا ان
المشاورات التجري على مدار الساعه
بدورها اعلنت بريطانيا نهايه رحلات
الاجلاء من السودان اعتبارا من اليوم
السبت وذلك بعدما اجلت اكثر من 1500 شخص
حتى الان وكانت الحكومه البريطانيه اعلنت
الثلاثاء الماضي بدا اجلاء مواطنيها بعد
موافقه طرفي الصراع على وقف اطلاق النار
لمده 72 ساعه واعطاء الاولويه لاجلاء من
يحملون جوازات سفر بريطانيه والاسر التي
تضم اطفالا وكبار السن الذين يعانون من
ظروف صحيه
شاده اجلت في غضون 48 ساعه
351 من مواطنيها الذين حصلوا في القتال
الدائر في السودان بعد وصول طائره ثالثه
الى انجمينا على متنها 130 راكبا وكشف
المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه ابراهيم ادم
محمد عن استقبال 130 عائدا بينهم خمسه عشر
طفلا و 34 مسنا رافقتهم فرق وكاله الهجره
التابعه للامم المتحده والتي احصت عددهم
هذا وكانت رحلتان جويتان مخصصتان للاجلاء
وصلتا الى العاصمه الجميله مساء الخميس من
بورتسودان وكان على متن طائرتين 221 شاديا
العربيه والحدث داخل مدينه بورسودان في
شرق السودان في هذا المركز الرئيس لحصر
وتنسيق وتوفيقي اوضاع مئات الاسر التي
وصلت الى شرق السودان في طريقها الى خارج
البلاد عديد الجاليات وعديد رعايه الدول
الاوروبيه والعربيه والافريقيه وصلت الى
مدينه
اوضاعها في هذا المركز كما تتابعون هذه
الاوضاع وهذه الصور وهذه المشاهد لمئات من
الاسر ما زالت تنتظر حتى الان مرت عليها
اكثر من خمسه ايام وهي تنتظر توفيق
الاوضاع والمغادره عبر البواخر والقطع
الحربيه البحريه التي تصل تباعا من
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ومن عديد الدول
في المنطقه هذا المركز هنالك جهات تشرف
على عمليه الحصر وعمليه توثيق الاوضاع
سواء كان من السفاره السعوديه او من
الشرطه السودانيه او اداره الجوازات
بالسودان لتوفيق عديد الرعايه والجاليات
التي وصلت الى شرق السودان هذه العمليه
مستمره مع استمرار هذه العمليه تزداد
صعوبه الاوضاع هنا داخل هذا المركز وفي
محيط هذا المركز وداخل هذه المدينه مع
ارتفاع اعداد الواصلين الى مدينه بورسودان
والى شرق السودان اكثر من 4000 سوري وصلوا
الى هذه المدينه اكثر من 1500 طالب ومن
رعايه دوله اليمن ووصلوا الى هذه المنطقه
مما يفاقم الاوضاع ويصعب كذلك عمليه توفيق
الاوضاع والاجراءات المتبعه حتى يغادر
السودان خلال الساعات المقبله ومع استمرار
هذه الاجراءات يستمر تدفق المئات من الاسر
الى مدينه بورسودان بشرق السودان في
طريقهم لمغادره البلاد نزار البداوي
لقناتي العربيه والحدث مدينه بورسودان
الشرقيه السودان
والان مشاهدينا نتابع معكم الصور لقوات
عسكريه تستعد للدخول الى الخرطوم مع
استمرار عمليات الاجلاء من العاصمه اذا
صور لقوات عسكريات تستعد للدخول الى
الخرطوم مع استمرار عمليات الاجلاء نستمع
الى الصوت الطبيعي
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا هذه صور لقوات عسكريه تستعد
للدخول الى الخرطوم مع استمرار عمليات
الاجلاء وكنا ايضا منذ قليل تابعنا صور
لقوات الشرطه تنتشر في كل الولايات في
في السودان في الخرطوم من اجل ضبط الامن
اذن اليوم نتابع صور
وقوات عسكريه تستعد للدخول الى الخرطوم
بالاضافه طبعا الى قوات الشرطه التي
تابعناها منذ قليل
منذ بدايه الصراع كان شارع الشجره في حي
الفتحات بمدينه ام درمان السودانيه شاهدا
على الاشتباكات بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريه حيث لا تزال حتى اليوم اصوات
الاشتباكات تسمع من سلاح المهندسين القريب
من الحي
المبادرات المفروض يكون بالضغط
ما بتكون يعني بالطريقه بتاعتك الليون
مبادراتي يكون في ضغط عديل على الجيش عليه
الدعم ناس يستمعوا عليها من سياسيين من
النعساكر من مجتمع المدني كلهم
مبادره ايا كانت هذه المبادره في سبيلنا
بس توقف الحرب وربنا يحفظ السودان لانه
السودان
لا لازم كل السودانيين المفروض
نجيب مواطنين كله سودانيين مزبوط الكلام
ادى الى تضرر الاقتصاد وشحان في الغذاء
وعجز في القدره الشرائيه بين الاهالي
وزياده الاسعار حتى اربعه اضعاف
حرب زادت من ثقل الوضع الاقتصادي على
الاهالي في السودان
ازمه امتدت في كل ولايه السودان واشتدت في
الولايات الشماليه
المواد الغذائيه بدا واضحا في سوق القرير
في مروي
ماما
شديد
ارتفاع في الاسعار وشبه عجز في القدره
الشرائيه للمواد الغذائيه ان وجدت
في عدم يعني
في رمضان كانت بالف ونصف
اي شيء قاعد يقعد
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي زاد الطين بالله
ما اضر بمخزون الغذاء بعد الاحداث
قالت
ان شاء الله
ومع استمرار المعارك يتوقع تضرر مخزون
الغذائي في عموم السودان لنحو كارثي
صحيفه امكانيه تقدم الجيش السوداني على
قوات الدعم السريع في الخرطوم بحكم
امكانيته العسكريه التي تفوق تلك التي لدى
الدعم السريع الا انها ايضا لم تستبعد
سيناريو اطاله امد النزاع على يد قوات
الدعم السريع وتحويله الى حرب استنزاف
نتابع
صراع على السلطه في السودان يخشى ان يتحول
الى حرب اكثر دمويه واطول امدا لكن طرفي
الصراع في العاصمه الخرطوم في وضعيتين
متباينتين فالقتال يجري بين مجموعتين
متفاوتتين في العدد والمعدات العسكريه
لها رصدت قدرات الطرفين ومدى امكانيه
استمرارهما في القتال لفتره طويله القوات
المسلحه بقياده البرهان تملك اكثر من 200
الف جندي جيش تقليدي يعرف شوارع الخرطوم
وتضاريسها مدرب على الدفاع عن تلك المواقع
بشكل جيد كما يدعمه سلاح الجو بتشكيله من
طائرات
ومدرعات وصواريخ عدا عن ادارته لمصنع
عسكري يزوده بالذخيره والعربات المدرعه في
الجهه المقابله يتوقع خبراء عسك ان قوات
الدعم السريع شبه العسكريه تقاتل بما يقرب
من 40 الف مسلح رغم ان مصادر في الدعم
السريع تقول ان عديدها يقترب من 150 الفا
وتعتمد هذه القوات على تشكيله واسعه من
مضادات الطائرات والعربات المدرعه لكنها
بطبيعه الحال لا تمتلك سلاحا جويا غير ان
هناك نقطه لصالح هذه القوات بحسب
وهي الرواتب المجزيه مقرنه برواتب الجيش
السوداني وبحكم خلفيه تجنيدها كجماعه
مسلحه قبليه في دارفور وعلى حدود تشاد لا
درايه لقسم من عناصر الدعم السريع بتضاريس
العاصمه ولم يسبق ان توغلت فيها كما تتوغل
الان غير انها نجحت في ابتكار مسارات
جديده لتوفير الدعم بالذخيره لابقاء
عناصرها قادرين على خوض معارك استنزاف
طويله لكن يبقى التحدي القائم امام الدعم
السريع هو كيفيه السيطره على العاصمه
الخرطوم وهو امر لم يحدث في التاريخ
القريب من اي حركه خارجه عن الجيش او من
محاولات التمرد المتعدده في السودان وعمر
العربيه
يعتمد الجيش السوداني في معاركه مع قوات
الدعم السريع على عده امور من اجل تحقيق
التفوق في العرض التالي نتعرف الى ابرز
مميزات ومكونات سلاح الجو السوداني
والقواعد العسكريه الكبرى في السودان في
كل المعارك القتال من الجو يكون فعالا
لبسط السيطره على الارض الجيش السوداني
لجا الى هذا السلاح لمنازله قوات الدعم
السريع اسطول القوات الجويه السودانيه
يعتمد بشكل اساسي على عشر مقاتلات من طراز
29 طائره تمنح الجيش نقطه تفوق بالنظر الى
ميزاتها المختلفه فهي مرنه تطلق صواريخ جو
ارض مقاتله تعتبر ردا تقنيا وعسكريا روسيا
على طائره اف 16 الامريكيه الجيش السوداني
يضم مجموعه اخرى من الطائرات سوفياتيه
الروسيه الصنع منها سبع طائرات من فئتي
ميغ 21 وميك 23 اضافه الى سبعه عشره
من فئتي 24 وسوق 25
ومقاتلات خفيفه من طراز جي 7
كيو خمسه من الصين واخرى متعدده المهام من
الجيل الثالث من طراز اف 5 تايغر من
الولايات المتحده القوه الجويه السودانيه
سبق واعلنت عن نجاحها في دمج الطائرات
المقاتله من الولايات المتحده والصين
وروسيا في شبكه واحده لتبادل البيانات في
العام 2018
حصيله القوات الجويه السودانيه من
الهليكوبترا المقاتله تصل الى 43 طائره من
نوع ميل ميلي اربعه وعشرين صاحبه التصميم
الكلاسيكي اضافه الى ثلاث طائرات هليكوبتر
نقل من الفئه 17 وكذلك 24 طائره من فئه من
ثمانيه في السودان ثماني قواعد جويه
ابرزها قاعده مروي العسكريه الواقعه
بولايه شمال السودان قاعده شهدت مواجهات
ضاريه بين الجيش والدعم السريع في بدايه
الصراع وقاعده وادي سيدنا في ام درمان
فضلا عن قاعده الاوبيض في شمال ولايه
كوردوفان ثم قاعده الخرطوم وسط العاصمه
ومع استمرار المواجهات تستعد الولايات
المتحده لفرض عقوبات جديده على افراد
الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع عقوبات تعيد
الى الاذهان تلك التي كانت مفروضه ايام
حكم الرئيس المخلوع عمر البشير بلال
البجدين العربيه
ومع استمرار الاشتباكات اكد برنامج الغذاء
العالمي في بيان ان الوضع في السودان اصبح
كارثيا وانا اسعار المواد الغذائيه ارتفعت
بشكل صاروخي واكد برنامج الغذاء العالمي
التزامه باستئناف عمليته في السودان داعيا
الى ضروره توقف القتال لافتا الى انه يجري
تقييما للوضع الامني في السودان لتحديد
المواقع الهادئه لتقديم المساعدات
قد تفجر حرب السودان في الشمال صمم الامان
الاخير لالتئام جراح جارتها في الجنوب
والتيعان طوال فتره الانفصال من حرب اهليه
شرسه اذ يبدو ان الازمات عادت لتوحد مصير
دولتين كانت فتره وحدتهما اطول من
انفصالهما الاسباب في التقرير التالي
بظروف صعبه وتوقيت بعيد عن الامثل يتحول
الشتات في الحروب الى ازمه قابله للتصدير
سريعا الى دول الجوار صراع الجنراللين دفع
نحو 15 الف نازح من السودانيين وجنوب
السودانيين للعبور الى الضفه الجنوبيه في
اقل من اسبوعين عدد سيصل ل 180 الفا في
ثلاثه اشهر فقط اذا استمر الاقتتال وفقا
لممثله الامم المتحده في جنوب السودان
الامن شبه المنعدم كان الدافع الرئيسيا
لهروب الاله في الى وجهه ليست اكثر امنا
وفقا لما تشير اليه منظمه الامم المتحده
فرحله الفرار الممتده ل500 كم تقريبا
ملغمه بالمخاطر تبدا من العاصمه بما يتوفر
من وسائل مواصلات او السير مشيا في احيان
والتعرض لخطر هجوم مسلح الى حين الوصول
الى ولايه الابيض اقرب نقطه حدوديه جنوبيه
للخرطوم هناك حيث يعيش نحو 300 الف جنوب
سوداني في المخيمات جلهم نزح من حرب اهليه
داميه في بلد لا يزال 75% من سكانه
يعتمدون على مساعدات انسانيه تتكفل بثلاثه
وعشرين بالمئه فقط من احتياجاتهم وضع
يزداد خطوره في ظل هشاشه اتفاق السلام
الموقعي عام 2018 بين فصائل الجنوب
والترقب لاول انتخابات في تاريخ البلاد
تجري نهايه العام المقبل وليس مستبعدا ان
تخلق حرب الشمال فرصه جديده لتنشيط جماعات
مسلحه يلجا اليها القاده المتمردون
الغاضبون من حكومه سيلفاكير رئيس دوله
جنوب السودان
حرب ستحرم كذلك عمليه السلام في الجنوب من
الضامن الاقليمي الاكثر نفوذا المتمثل في
ضغوط البرهانه على قاده الجنوب في ملفات
امنيه واقتصاديه ولعل اسوا العواقب
الاقتصاديه تلك التي تهدد خط انابيب النفط
العابر للحدود الى بورتسودان وتحرم وجوبا
من عائدته التي يتقاسمها مع السودان لكن
القضيه الاكثر الحاحا هي تامين خروج اكثر
من 800 الف جنوب سوداني يقطن معظمهم في
الخرطوم واستغلال معاناتهم من تجار الازمه
الذين يعرضون خدمات التوصيل بمبلغ يصل الى
ثمانيه الاف دولار للحافله في ظل انقطاع
الخدمات الامميه هناك كرم حناوي العربيه
والان الى قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه في
جده مع مراسل العربيه هاني نصفيان الذي
يتابع مغادره مجموعه من موظفي الامم
المتحده الذين تم اجلائهم اليوم من
السودان اليك هاني الاجواء لديك
نعم اهلا بك ميسون مره اخرى العربيه تواكب
مغادره وكذلك وصول عمليات الاجلاء وكذلك
مغادرتهم سواء من الموانع التي حدثتها
السعوديه وكذلك من قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه التي نتواجد فيها الان
في هذه اللحظات يصل وفد او الدفعه الاولى
من بعثه الامم المتحده التي وصلت اليوم
عبر سفينه امانا وهي وصلت الان الى قاعده
الملك عبد الله الجويه استعدادا لمغادرتها
عموما سوف يكون ضيفي الاستاذ محمد الغنيم
وهو ممثل في الامم المتحده مرحبا بك استاذ
محمد على شاشه العربيه بينما نطرح عليك
السؤال في هذه اللحظات وايضا بعدها كاميرا
العربيه سوف تتجول على البيئه التي وصلت
دعنا نتحدث عن العدد الذي وصل الان واين
سيذهب والمرحله المقبله بالنسبه لهم
حاليا هذا
الخطوه او القسم الثاني من عمليه الاخلاق
المتفق عليها مع مقام وزاره الخارجيه
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
وعددهم 151 تقريبا
تم اجلائهم بسفينه امانه من ميناء بور
السودان الى ميناء جده الاسلامي
وتم نقلهم الى قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه حيث سيتم تجهيز طائره
لهم
خلال الدقائق القادمه
وسينتقلون ان شاء الله الى دوله كينيا
مدينه نيروبي ومنها سيكون هناك اتصال
للرحله الى
الى دوله اوغندا طيب اولا دعنا نتعرف عن
هذه الطائره ما هي نوعيه الطائره هل هي
طائره تجاريه من طائره خاصه بالامم
المتحده
ولماذا تحديدا
نيروبي يعني
هي طائره
طائرهم متعاقده مع
قمها
بالنسبه
للجزء في سؤالك لماذا نيروبي بانه
بعد احداث السودان هي دوله كينيا وعاصمتها
نور نيروبي
وتم اعداد الخطه مع
[موسيقى]
المقام وزاره الخارجيه بهذا الشان
هل مازال هناك عالقين بالنسبه لاعضاء
الامم المتحده في السودان ام جميعهم وصلوا
الى جده وكذلك تم اجلائهم
بفضل الله ثم بفضل المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
نستطيع ان نقول ان شاء الله انه هؤلاء
حاليا
الاخير اخر دفعه المتفق عليها لكن لا نعلم
السودان الان اصبحت منطقه الطوارئ
ممكن انه يكون في طلب اخر نعم ممكن يكون
في طلب اخر لكن حاليا الطلب تم اقفال جميع
طلبات الاخلاء من بور السودان يعني ما زال
هناك في اعداد ولكن لم يتم طلب لم يتم
الطلب
وفي حاله طلب مقام وزاره الخارجيه تدعم
عام العمل الاممي
مسخره لنا وان شاء الله سنطلب منهم
المساعده مره اخرى استاذ محمد غنيم ممثل
الامم المتحده هنا في السعوديه اذا ايضا
شاهدنا ايضا اعضاء بعثه الامم المتحده
التي وصلت اليوم عبر سفينه امانه والتي
والذين ايضا هم في قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه وهم يستعدون الان ولكن يتم انهاء
اجراءاتهم بشكل سريع من قبل الجوازات
السعوديه تماما للمرحله التي بعدها التي
سوف يغادرون الى نيروبي تفضل
باقي الزملاء لنتابع معكم لحظه بلحظه وصول
ومغادره كل الرعايه والبعثات التي تصل من
بورتسودان الى السعوديه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات